ايضا مع هذه الزلازل هناك متلازمه السحق
او الهرس وهي كابوس يلاحق السوريين
الناجين من تحت الانقاض وهو ما حذر منه
الدفاع المدني شمال سوريا ما هي متلازمه
الهرس مشاهدينا هي حاله خطيره تنتج عن
الضغط الشديد والمطول على احد اعضاء الجسم
ومن الممكن ان تؤدي الى الموت في الاثنتين
وسبعين ساعه الاولى لذلك يحتاج لرعايه
صحيه خاصه
ومتقدمه الاطباء ممن تواجدوا وعالجوا
بزلزال تركيا وسوريا تحدثوا عن ان اكثر
المشاكل الصحيه التي تهدد حياه الناجين من
تحت الركام هي الاضرار المباشره العظميه
والعصبيه اضافه لتلك التي ينتج عنها نزيف
البطن او الاحشاء او الرئه من اخطر تلك
الامراض ايضا ما يعرف بمت
نسبه السوائل في الجسم الى المعدل الطبيعي
وهي احد اهم الاسباب التي تؤدي الى وفاه
الناجين من تحت الركام خلال الاثنتين
وسبعين ساعه الاولى بعد الانقاذ ماذا يوصل
اطباء يوصوا دوما بان مصابي متلازمه الهرس
هم بحاجه الى كثير من جلسات غسيل الكلى
لضبط الكرياتينين وايضا اليوريا
والبوتاسيوم وقبل ذلك يصوم ببدء معالجه
المصابين من موقع الحادث وهذا مهم جدا
[موسيقى]